the move towards statehood for
washington d.c
has reached a critical stage tonight
lawmakers in the democratic-controlled
house voted to approve that measure
make d.c estate which now faces an
uncertain future
in the senate the vote in the house was
216 to 208
here's congressional correspondent chad
pergram
republicans say d.c lacked statehood
chops
it was not set up to be a state no or
minimal manufacturing agriculture and
natural resources
republicans suspect the d.c statehood
bill is a chess piece
in a broader democratic political game
pure power grab to give
two democrat senators to district of
columbia
democrats say they just want fairness
for d.c
they don't see taxation without
representation
all that they see is two new liberal
democrat senators
house majority leader steny hoyer says
that may be the case now
but not forever when alaska and hawaii
were
admitted not too far apart in years
alaska was perceived to be a democratic
state and hawaii was perceived to be a
republican state
the politics of alaska and hawaii
flipped over time
but two more senators now could tilt the
political playing field
toward the democrats let me tell you
what democrat support is really about
of h.r 51 democratic partisanship
democrat power democrats contend gop
opposition to statehood
israeli code one senate republican said
that d.c wouldn't be a quote
well-rounded working-class state
i had no idea there were so many
syllables in the word white one
republican argued d.c
lacked a landfill prompting this from
jones
with all the racist trash my colleagues
have brought to this debate
i can see why they're worried about
having a place to put it on every topic
they go to race
and if you oppose whatever radical
agenda they're trying to
push they call you a racist the d.c bill
likely faces a senate filibuster
which democrats hope to use as a wedge
to eventually
unwind the filibuster we need to make
the filibuster
too hot to handle house speaker nancy
pelosi ducked my question
if she supports getting rid of the
filibuster the speaker said she doesn't
get involved in senate rules and doesn't
want senators involved in the rules
of the house brett chad there's a great
sound bite there too hot to handle for
the filibuster
specifically for senators mansion and
from west virginia and cinema from
arizona right right that's uh two who
are in play here you know i would also
look at mark kelly
uh there's also been some other senators
who've kept rather quiet who might be in
play also
all right we'll follow this definitely
chad thanks republicans have tapped gop
south carolina the gop
has tapped tim scott is that right to
deliver the response
chad right the rebuttal to the president
is one of the most
prized assignments a politician can have
tim scott
he's the only black gop senator he
authored a police reform bill last year
after george floyd died
democrats blocked that bill because it
wouldn't pass the house now scott has
spoken in emotional terms about his own
encounters with police even here on
capitol hill
as a u.s senator and scott is working
with democratic lawmakers
on a possible police reform bill now
brett
all right we'll follow all that as well
chad thanks